hey welcome to the Reuben report I'm
Dave Rubin this is YouTube we got a move
I've got Cara Santa Maria and Jen
Hoffman with me and it has been a week
of scandals and it's gonna be probably a
month the scandals and perhaps a year of
scandals there's so many to choose from
between the AP IRS Benghazi everyone has
a favorite and Newt Gingrich who no one
listened to when he was running for
president said this week that the GOP
may be over playing their hand when it
comes to all this scandal stuff
basically because people still seem to
like Obama and Hillary Clinton more than
the GOP themselves so ladies do you have
a favorite scandal and which scandal
could it possibly be carried like
favorite currents a favorite could not
scandal however you want to take that I
left it open-ended for you um right well
I was a weird question as to what's my
favorite skin it could be a personal
escape well if I'm gonna look through
the three choices that you just I think
I don't think my favorite that's a super
weird way to say it but I don't really
think Benghazi I'm still unsure as to
whether or not that is a scandal at all
okay so obviously right exactly you're
watching that's the biggest scandal ever
but that's just basically like bigger
that's again exactly they're making it
huge cuz you know they're making their
plan so in four years they could say oh
my god Hillary Clinton she's so
inappropriate and she sucks and she's a
problem and it's not a it's not even a
thing no one really cares it's like a
it's like a thing we don't know we drink
about yeah what you said I mean I think
in some ways and I think Newt is on to
this it's actually making them look bad
right you know what I mean it's making
the GOP look this is why Obama's numbers
haven't changed his polling data hasn't
changed at all because I think people
are still kind of unsure and when they
see the GOP like overblowing it and sort
of the the conservative media over
blowing it it's so obvious yeah it's
just too obvious okay so Benghazi were
throwing Benghazi
okay that's the that's number three so
then I think someone has to do it we
need it like an official order otherwise
people don't waste good I like favor
you mean like what's the worst is the
most legitimate okay works for ya
Benghazi do you think AP or the IRS
situation the IRS seems to be the one
that today people are really talking
about a lot but I mean I think from a
personal perspective obviously the AP
phone hack is probably the scariest to a
table of people who probably have worked
in journalism before but the IRS I think
a scandal is probably the most obviously
illegal yeah one's a little sexier or
more interesting just because when you
find people are being audited using
keywords that's a little bit scarier
because I'm obviously also as
journalists and as people that blog and
have YouTube channels and stuff we're
all using certain keywords out there too
so we can find ourselves on the other
end of that where you know we don't know
who the next president is or this
president or who it's not necessarily
either the IRS works directly for the
president supposed to be separate but
that's scary the implication that if
you're saying things against him that
the IRS might just audit you but I think
the AP one is a little bit scarier
because they're just listening to you
and if you're a journalist you really
that's like saying it's like being in
China you know that's a thing in some
other country where you can't actually
have free reign yeah to you know be a
journalist and and do your job yeah now
we've been talking about this quite a
bit on the show but people don't realize
that the Department of Justice has
already said that they can go into all
of our emails our Facebook messages our
Twitter DMS they're allowed to do that
right now why is it that people don't
seem to care about that no no they think
it won't happen to them people have that
mentality of Walter not doing nothing
wrong then why does it apply to me right
I'm not planning a you know there's so
many people I think that we maybe
because again bring up the journalism
thing we're so used to being conscious
of that and understanding it but a lot
of people think this doesn't involve me
why would they look through my stuff
they're not listening to me they don't
care so they think it doesn't apply to
that yeah do you think people realize
how short-sighted it is to be like well
I'm not doing anything wrong so
a lot of them do I think a lot of
conservatives have a big problem with
this which is strange because it was a
conservative policy that was first put
forth but but I think the real issue
here is that most you know your average
Joe isn't a journalist and doesn't have
sources to protect and I think that
that's the real issue with the AP
scandal is that they're they're certain
there's you know journalistic integrity
that you have to uphold it's part of
your job and it's very important to you
and it's kind of a badge of honor and
it's different if you're talking about
kind of your everyday person who is just
going to work and trying to raise their
family and not involved in any sort of
like political things that if we look
into their their doings we're not really
gonna find anything and I mean yeah it
is short-sighted to think that way
because you know you give an inch okay
come on I think you know it's also the
whole 9/11 thing is once you know the
Patriot Act came about people were
afraid to say anything about it cuz
terrorism and that just that word in
this country here terrorists everyone
freaks out and goes do what you got to
do you don't want terrorism so people
will say great you know audit whoever
has a key word go through our stuff you
know people will really allow access to
our personal information thinking well
I'm not a terrorist I'm not doing
anything wrong I'm not planning anything
and that's just so like just it's such
an ill-conceived idea that you know cuz
someday you could be just politically
active or sending an email or doing
something and get flagged and you're
it's a generational cap I mean we
weren't around during McCarthyism we
didn't see that happening and we're so
used to social media we're so used to
things like you know Google and Facebook
knowing our preferences and we
appreciate that we want it to autofill
for us we've have the nice suggestions
it does make life easier and so we see
it coming from these corporations and I
think it's hard to discriminate the
difference between the Justice
Department doing that you know or
between between the government doing
that and these specific corporations
doing it it's it's a huge gendered I
mean not gender generational difference
I see with my parents for example they
won't use like a credit card online yeah
they're really paranoid about credit
card it could be the biggest corporation
you could be like you know Macy's or
something that's been around forever and
they're like well we're not gonna buy
something online because they might
steal our information and I'm like the
magical elf stealing your credit card
like our parents generation may actually
be safer in the digital world just
because they're basically when change
occurs you know you're you're kind of
uncomfortable with change and you want
to look under every rock and try to
understand it and when you're born into
something when it's kinda I mean I
wasn't born into the internet era but
you know we're not that we're but but I
know people who were obviously they are
around and I had the internet by the
time I was in college so it is kind of
still part of my DNA all right well
we're gonna get to more social media
stuff in a little bit but final and
final point on this how much do you
think because nobody seems to like the
Republicans if you look at the polls
it's like they're congressional approval
rating is that like six percent or
something so how much of this is just
that they're just throwing anything
against the wall just is this really
just to bang up Hillary cuz I kind of
agree with you this is just to bang
Hillary enough that sounded weird to
just damage her so that at least the
Benghazi and at least Democrats in
general and I think we Republicans are
grasping at straws and really as an
independent leaning independent I'm
still an independent at that I wouldn't
have a problem voting for a Republican
that I thought was saying or not making
a sterile mess of everything and I think
the most important thing that Newt
Gingrich said in all this was two things
I haven't heard Republicans saying so
long as he said let's be calm and
factual yeah and for him to say that
that's like that has been so the direct
opposite of what the party and some of
their you know biggest media
cheerleaders like Fox News Fox News
they'd only to be common factual they
like to be like hysterical and as
inaccurate as possible although that was
our original call let's move on and
actually this is about a guy that knows
a little something about scandals to the
Pope was in st. Peter's Square a couple
days ago and he might have just given an
exorcism in front of everybody let's
take a look
okay so it's a it's a little unclear to
me whether the music was actually
playing at that one Count Dracula
alright so there's so many ways we can
go with this so first off because I know
you're both exorcism specialists would
you say that that was an exorcism Jen
I've had it in way wilder than that no
no you can't tell I mean look this is
the one thing I will say about faith
healing type things when you're a family
and you have someone who's ill and
you're desperate sometimes a little
faith can go a long way emotionally for
you so for me it doesn't look like you
did anything like violent unacceptable
anything that was hurting this person so
to me it's like I don't really give a
[ __ ] if it's an exorcism if it made the
family feel a little bit better right
now Cara I know you're not big on
religion to say the least
I'm not a believer I'm an atheist so
what me like I don't see the difference
maybe that's a prayer or an exorcism
they're both equally same thing to me
it's all the faith healing is all the
same to me whether he was like I bless
you my son you're now absolved you're
gonna get up and walk and run marathons
or he shook his head around and didn't
exercise the same thing to you okay so
for someone though that crazy for
someone though that is an atheist if
what he did even if it didn't have any
tangible like real spiritual thing going
on but if the person who was there the
handicapped person was healed by it
somehow even if they just tricked
themselves does that seem like a good
thing to you they didn't happen that's
not what happened that's not going that
person's gonna be any better if that
person has like MS or cerebral palsy or
you know some some legitimate biological
ailment that's putting them in that
wheelchair
trust me the Pope did not just do that
that's not even like worth I think
you're responding to I just don't it
that would be a miracle you know what I
mean and miracles don't happen not not
in the spiritual sense but but like I
said I think that the idea of whether
it's a prayer or an exorcism it's all
the same and truth be told in Catholic
dogma I mean the Pope is a priest right
or he's a what do you call a conduit god
yeah and they all they all have the
power to perform exercies
yes and I think this Pope specifically
has performed exorcisms before so it's
not really that surprising right so why
do you think the church like immediately
they were like no no was it an exorcism
and you know dude why do they feel like
leading followers and the word exorcism
is very intense I think first of all and
second of all I think that if you I
think that's a problem where a lot of
people now will be you know faith
healing instead of getting medical
treatment like what you were saying if
he has cerebral palsy PSMs if he's not
seeking actual treatment or doesn't have
the money or means to get that and is
relying on the church to cure him I
think that could freak people out some
people could attack the church saying
you're replacing actual means and health
and real you know medical procedures
with that so that's why they back away I
also think they're trying to be more
modern as a religion I think this Pope
is viewed as a more progressive more
modern Pope and when you say that about
every exorcism we think of like the
Middle Ages I just don't think that it's
good PR for them if they do come out and
say this was a you know on-the-fly
exorcism that he just perform right in
public yeah we're gonna talk a little
bit more about religion later but does
this show you like why religion in the
modern day sort of is just kind of
bonkers because even something even
something just a quiet reaching to the
to this preached already I guess but
because that perhaps if they believed
something good is about this
they can't even say it and that's kind
of bizarre isn't it I mean I think if
you're if you do think something's great
about it and they think this was a good
thing for their church and this is
something they do regularly then stand
up and say it be like we're gonna be
doing exorcisms y'all like just come on
down come get it y'all that's what I
think if I always think of those when
they have the huge churches and people
are coming up the steps and they're
doing the faith healing or that exactly
so what is that okay so as yeah right no
no but I mean what is it actually like
in the in the human is that this need to
be connected to sighing so badly that
even if it's not real it's the same
thing as
hypnotism which there is evidence to
show that people can be hypnotized but
it's all about susceptibility it's all
about wanting it bad enough and and kind
of finding yourself in that headspace
and so people who speak in tongues I
think they do truly believe that there's
some sort of I don't know if it's
supposed to be positive or negative but
some sort of spirit running through them
that is possessing them and allowing
them to do that we know objectively that
that's not what's happening but it's not
like these people are always charlatans
I think a lot of them actually think
that it's occurring right have you ever
just been like really sick or something
bad has happened and you found yourself
being like please God did it even if you
don't believe in God or you're not
religious you just cuz I'm not I'm
pretty much agnostic atheist I walk that
line I have faith in something larger
than me but I certainly don't I don't
believe in God as his prescribe judging
you certainly don't believe in any
organized religion nor do I think it's
healthy for people I think it's a crutch
and almost like a mental illness bla bla
bla but that being said I do think that
sometimes when you're just in need and
weak you know and I hate to say that
people wanna go no religion makes me
strong but a lot of the time it is when
you need faith whether it's a specific
religion or whether it's just some sort
of universal universe please help me
you'll find yourself to something oh
please let this happen or please protect
me and I think that's when you get the
most desperate people because if you're
that person in a wheelchair not walking
that's when you're gonna be looking
towards a faith healing or an exorcism
because you're you're desperate and
you're sad and you're hurting and you're
in pain and so is your family
I think that's common I mean I don't
think that personally applies to me
because a theism is a big part of like
my kind of cultural identity so you know
when they say there are no atheists in
foxholes like trust me I'd be an atheist
in a foxhole like that you'd still hold
on to it at that oh yeah I've never like
asked God like oh I left the church I've
never asked a god for anything I've
never kind of found myself on my knees
that's not to say I wouldn't if for some
reason there was real evidence too but
that's not gonna happen but you're right
I do think that it's the same it's this
whether it's religious or whether it's
kind of last-ditch kind of medical not
legitimate medicine you know alternative
and there are and sometimes these are
these are very negative because there
are people who will take advantage of
people when they're very sick and very
week but when all of your options are
extinguished it can have something of a
placebo effect yeah well to put a cap on
this most of the things I learned about
religion and God and science was from
watching the movie contact after eating
pot brownies so ok let's move on to
something that actually is a real
empirical thing happening right now
there is a new disorder it is called
SMED social media anxiety disorder and
I'm 99% sure that I suffer from this
this is the endless condition where we
find ourselves having to tweet and
Instagram all our food and constantly be
locked into this digital world and
they're actually starting to prescribe
this to people and say that this is a
real medical disorder do you guys do you
suffer from this Jen first of all I like
tripping out right now but we do any
time any new thing happens anytime
culture shifts anytime something happens
they of course have to associate a
disorder with it I don't know if it's
necessarily a disorder more is just a
natural phenomenon that happens when
people are extremely tied to their
devices I certainly feel that I
certainly will get that like Facebook or
it didn't happen type thing which is
insanity or certainly find myself
rabbit holing into you know the web for
a while and I know they say people that
spend more time on the internet get more
depressed so I can I can see how this is
a real thing but I'm also waiting to see
what pharmaceutical company wants to hop
on board and now prescribe whatever to
detach you from this yeah and and one of
the fascinating things is that they show
you that you know you feel like you
should be more connected is what
everyone says well I want to be more
connected with everybody and yet they
show you all the time that you're more
disconnected because it looks like oh
everyone else's food is cooler and their
Instagram filters better I like real
syndrome so basically like if you know
in television basically when you when
you see a movie it's like trailer
syndrome you're seeing a best-of so most
people aren't like when I'm sitting home
in bed like eating nachos sobbing
you know it's like the one time you find
we're making the depressed Instagrammer
that's actually pretty things just a
bummer I have to kind of go against a
little bit of what you guys are saying
here just from it's easy to be flip and
kind of cynical about this but truth be
told this is not a diagnosable disorder
right now it's not in the ICD it's not
in the DSM so all of the diagnostic
tools that physicians and psychiatrists
use and psychologists use there's no
such thing as social media anxiety
disorder and so it does it's oftentimes
I think what happens is that if an
individual does have a clinical issue
with anxiety they're gonna be different
kind of behavioral aspects of their life
that they'll latch on to you know if you
look at a generalized anxiety disorder
it's a little hard to pinpoint but if
you look at obsessive compulsive
disorder that's also listed as an
anxiety - yeah really what it is is that
there's there's an anxiety welling up
and that helps you kind of keep it in
check periodically and so it could be
that there are people who already
possess a deep anxiety and the social
media kind of addiction feeds to that I
think that there's also a like you said
a shift in culture and we are connected
to our technology now and yes it it
might make me nervous if I forget my
phone and I leave it at home for six
hours but is that because I'm afraid I'm
gonna miss that email from work that's
really important isn't it the same thing
as feeling nervous that like you don't
have your call your house keys handy or
or for whatever reason I mean I think
that there is a legitimate side to this
and it's easy for us to kind of like I
said be cynical about it but being
disconnected from your social media can
actually have adverse effects on your
work and your social life some people
this is their form of socialization yeah
and I don't see that as being
potentially negative I just see it as
being you know part of the world we live
in do you guys think that part of this
is that we got all this stuff at once
like this is all new in the last 10
years we got all of it and now it's like
when I walk my dog the other day I
forgot my phone and I walked for a half
hour of no phone and the whole time I
kept putting my hand in my pocket like
I've got to be tweeting about the dog no
I know and then I loved it yes I loved
it and I actually
I do it on purpose I'm job two Sundays
ago I took the full day off I announced
it I am taking the day off he's dead
somewhere he's not done face we must be
dead
clearly you've been on Facebook or
Twitter or Instagram it'll check every
single Avenue Mageau have you been in
there 20 like my sister ones I didn't
update anything for like two or three
days and she legitimately was like I was
very concerned she had been sick it was
that's of course babies but of course
that's based on previous pattern cuz
you've probably never gone two days
before and I think that's important you
guys have like a particular one that has
more power over your day-to-day
operations is it for me it's Twitter by
this because we're all in this
talky-talk world so Twitter is just the
perfect comedian breaking news you know
it's first trending topics you can kind
of expel information Facebook is for at
least for me more people I know what
they're up to and you're having a baby
and you just need a sandwich or whatever
but Twitter really is you can tell
what's trending what's on people's mind
it's almost completely given up on like
my personal facebook I do have a page on
Facebook but I see that more as kind of
part of my daily promotional routine my
daily routine where I get in touch with
people and I kind of will sit at my
computer to work to do more page things
whereas with Twitter it's an all-day
everyday stream that's in my pocket I
very rarely will tweet from my computer
it's almost always from my iPhone so I
think I'm just much more active and that
I also don't Instagram or Pinterest at
all they do not interest me so you're
not planning your wedding at okay
basically it's like if you're a girl new
in Pinterest never show to your
boyfriend's just a wedding it's just
it's a lot of wedding stuff it's a lot
of cats the cats in the Internet really
I don't
I'm a dog yeah why do people love cats
I'm a dog girl but cats are hilarious
I'm a cat person so I'm the wrong person
to talk about how much I've zero which
is very strange I'm like I said some
woman's are like like I don't have any
babies I'm sad I'm like I have no keys
how did he catch the unknown I'm a cat
person okay you don't lady imaginary
yeah
in my hand I have 19 Wow that's funny
alright let's let's move on we're gonna
keep this science situation going I
definitely had the right panelists for
this one there is a new trend in
parenting which is they are teaching
science and rational thought instead of
religion crazy all right Cara we're
gonna start with you on this one to me
this seems like a very evolved way of
thinking and you're you're giving sort
of a decent honest set of rules to go
out into the world with I think you're
going to agree with that
is this how you were brought up because
you are raised Mormon
I was raised Mormon and half my family
still why a functioning a highly
functioning Mormon I left the church at
14 yeah I know a fair amount of X
Mormons who who did something similar
also like I said half probably more than
half of my family is still in the church
I have friends who were raised with no
religion in the household and that are
atheist now I have friends who were
raised with no religion that found
religion later I think that it's really
anybody's journey
what does frustrate me a little bit is
when people when I tell people that I
was raised Mormon they go that's why
you're an atheist and it's like no
that's not why I'm an atheist I mean I
think everybody's story contributes to
this really multifaceted kind of you
know a woven picture of why they believe
what they believe or have lack of belief
I personally think that raising children
I don't like the headline to believe in
science like when people go oh you
believe in evolution yeah and that's
something I would have to at back when I
was teaching biology and teaching
psychology that's something I had to
fight against a lot that it's not a
belief structure it's it's a method but
um I personally think that not believing
in God is the default position children
are indoctrinated to have religious
ideas right if you didn't teach them
religion they wouldn't naturally be
religious they will have actually fine
religious children naturally ask
questions they're naturally curious they
asked why they could fit why face why is
this why is the sky blue why is this
happening
so then the adults around them in the
authorities or the people that give them
that information they're the ones that
used to say the sky is blue because of
you know refractory this and that or
they get to stay because God made it
that way and simplify things for novel
transits that's easier for the hairy
exactly they don't know the real answer
mom and dad aren't necessarily educated
and don't know the answer or they are
educated and they're just busy so
they're just like because it is that way
and what scares me is that the headline
is that this is now a trend but science
is being - I mean it's like religious
and you raise your child in a church you
should still be you know kind of
fostering scientific curiosity in your I
mean I went to church I grew up in
basically like a it was Methodists and
Presbyterians back back and forth so in
a Christian you know Sunday school
certainly learned all about you know
that form of in my school that I went to
we learned science and we learned math
and they did not tell us that it was
because of ever because of God we
learned evolution and even in my church
they left it open to interpretation they
were like you know there's a bit of
science in this world and a little bit
of faith I mean there's such a
combination I feel like that was so so
much more appropriate for a child than
to tell a child to be less curious about
facts right so as to people that grew up
with some sort of religious background
in a way you have to kind of give it
credit for the to forming your thoughts
now right even if you would prefer that
every child be brought up with the
church I am Who I am because of all of
my experience everyone you know everyone
is I can't say that I would be better or
worse if I hadn't been raised Mormon I
think I have a perspective that a lot of
people don't have I'll tell you I
probably enjoyed the Book of Mormon the
play at least there's that
no I mean yeah everybody is who they are
because of because of their vast
experiences but I personally if I
decided to have children would
definitely raise them to be curious
scientific thinkers and I would want
them to be able to explore all these
different aspects on their own I would
want them to be able to come to their
own conclusions based on available
evidence but not based on in dark
nation and I think that's the important
distinction that yeah how would you feel
if you brought your child up in this
scientific learning space but then they
became religious I feel like that's a
part of the manger people kids are going
to explore and she was whatever they
want I was very grateful that my parents
let me I went to Temple I went to Mormon
Church I went to everything I've been to
a mosque when I was a child my parents
let me go wherever I went to Catholic
school classes with my friend out of
curiosity and my parents were cool with
that and my parents were kind of
conservative and not necessarily the
Republican you wouldn't necessarily
consider them progressive but in terms
of that they really allowed me to
explore so I feel like that allows a
child to make decision so if my child
came to me because I fully plan on
raising my child in science and math
we're so behind as a country by the way
just to interject that in a country that
falls so far behind in science and math
for it to be a problem or a new trend
for us to be teaching that's just that
that's the craziest part we want to be
competitive and we're going overseas and
Obama you're putting people in China and
people are losing their minds that when
you call you know a call center for tech
help that you're getting somebody in
Indonesia or India or something well
then teach your kids in science in
America and don't teach them that God is
one who's gonna fix your iPhone the only
reason I'm not getting as worked up as
right now is because I would literally
say this every day anybody who actually
like like follow some of the work that
I've done before I mean cuz that's what
I do I'm a science communicator that's
my background and the whole thing is
about like we need to think more
scientifically we need more
evidence-based thinking more critical
thinking and the beauty of this is that
all the religious nut jobs who don't
agree with you guys on this are gonna be
yelling at us in the comments correct
can't wait they're doing it for Greece
for Berlin yeah all right let's move
from a religion to porn because it is a
fine line between the two so lately
banks have been pulling back funding
from porn companies so JPMorgan Chase is
now involved in a lawsuit with
MRG entertainment which is a porn
company they don't want to back porn
anymore because of quote moral reasons
now I'm pretty sure that everyone
watches porn I've
research on this and yeah everyone
watches porn most people don't have a
problem with it but there still seems to
be this morality attached to it which I
really just don't understand anymore
because porn has become so mainstream so
is this just like old school
ridiculousness
I mean I mean the thinking from the bank
I don't want to say I understand both
sides because I really don't understand
where the banks are coming from I think
the only real valid argument the banks
could make if I'm gonna play devil's
advocate is that so many banks have
recently come under fire for doing kind
of like bad trading and for you know for
doing general unethical I think like you
don't necessarily have the means to pay
back the loan or not yeah there's the
the mortgage crisis with the with the
housing bubble but also some like you
know offshore kind of involvement whole
area so they can do sort of financially
irresponsible and immoral things when it
comes to sex I mean that's much more
unethical and I would see if there was a
heightened fear about record-keeping or
whatever that that might play into it
but that's not why they're not doing
this they're not doing this because
they're saying that there's some sort of
[ __ ] morality clause and it's
probably just one guy who doesn't feel
comfortable you know the president of
that specific branch weirdest porn and
by the way he's the guy who's looking up
like snuff monkey Dunkey porn at like
acid trip like he's watching at home
dude I can't fund this because I'm
creepy if you don't want to be involved
financially and legally if you don't
want to be tied to a company that is
doing things that aren't legal but the
porn industry is legal yeah this is a
business and and they should have the
same treatment of every potential client
especially when they're dealing with
government bailout money when they're
dealing with government funding when
they're no longer a completely private
entity they need to be you know obeying
these kind of fair lending yeah does
this kind of thing seem crazier now
because porn has become so mainstream I
mean people are literally making porn
right now in their bedroom with a webcam
and it's kind of so it's just out there
all the time we could all have access to
porn right this set we could all be
watching porn
so ridiculous is that now we just we all
know that people watch porn it's a
fourteen billion dollar industry most
like legitimate porn companies have made
a lot of money if you're a banker
probably making a mistake not lending to
one that has it's books and orders and
it's numbers in order because they're
thriving and they're not going anywhere
so it's kind of silly just from a
political point for a bank to
financially to say don't corns not
Willona back there's no money in porn
that's just ridiculous and foolish for
somebody but you know they're lending
money to tobacco firearms spirits
alcohol companies that make stuff with
GMO pesticides I mean the list goes on
and on the people that they regularly
lend money to openly that are actually
really hurting people and there's
actually clear and present danger for
using those products yeah and there's no
problem with that but porn which is what
is it illegal animal I mean we could
talk about this community this could be
every show for the rest of the year but
what is it fundamentally about sex
because you're right there's all these
things that we all know are far worse
fear I mean and I have to interject and
I'm not changing the subject at all but
I feel like I can bring it back my
particular viewers would be upset with
me if I didn't say that I disagree with
you about adding GMO to that list but
moving on from there I personally think
that you know coming from a religious
background and and sort of being able to
empathize with individuals who are
religious in that way even though I
disagree with them I think there's kind
of a fear of judgment that comes from
the sex stuff there's like a shame
component tied to it that's different
than a lot of these other there should
be a shame component tied to most of
those things that logically not that's
true and so the issue I think is that oh
well if we back this if we're involved
with this then how are we gonna be
perceived from the outside I don't think
it's an intrinsic moral issue I think
it's a it's a fear of retribution and
it's a shame thing my big question here
is is this against the law I mean I
don't know the legality of it I think it
is there are fair lending laws in place
and they have a legal operation that's
not violating anything your papers are
in order you have your whether it's your
LLC your escort people have that in
order and you're mean tonight alone just
based on morality there are certain
companies that have like Johnson &
Johnson has morality clauses there for
their employees
contract it's 9 degrees in volunteer the
lawsuit is saying that they're violating
their own contract and now we're doing
because it's a fair lending practices
and once you start violating that based
on it then it's again a slippery slope
thing and you can just say you know we
don't like your past so we're not gonna
loan to you you at one point we're a
stripper so now you can't get a home
loan completely different than like a
private restaurant who says that they
reserve the right not to serve somebody
and even then we've seen a lot of
lawsuits coming out even though there
are some laws kind of protecting private
institutions from doing that but a bank
that's almost completely public at this
point I think yeah is gonna be have
stricter laws kind of that they have to
uphold that yeah you know it's funny
what I was looking at this story it was
reminding me of do you guys see Boogie
Nights and you know Don Cheadle plays
buck who is a porn star who his whole
dream is to start this small business
and then we can't get the yeah he wants
to start a stereo business he can't get
the money because they see he's
important he ends up getting it in a
shadier way it also reminds me and I
know that this seems off-topic but in my
way I'm drawing kind of a parallel here
when you look at kids who have drug
offenses kids who have been arrested for
you know smoking a joint they can no
longer get government aid to be able to
attend college like these are the kids
that probably made it I was a high
school teacher for at-risk kids I'm in
high school that I taught at was for
children that had been thrown out of
their other high schools and usually it
was for smoking cigarette smoking some
of them were no longer allowed to attend
public school and have access to public
education because they got caught with
pot yeah and I mean the interesting
thing is that these are governmental
practices and these are laws that in
place that are in place but what happens
what ends up happening is it's like a
self-propagating issue because the
people who need the help the most are
the people who are turned away and I
think that you're right a lot of these
people who work in these industries are
working very hard to prove that they
have a legitimate practice going on you
know which in the state I was teaching
was really gone it's complete legal it's
not prostitution it's not it's not human
sex trafficking it's something that's
completely legal accessible and most of
the country and most people not only
watch it but enjoy it but it's not Shane
it has this big
shame across it alright I think we
nailed that one we were pretty clear now
you do about porn and sexy stories upon
all right let's move from porn to STDs
because some people have sex with other
people not just with themselves I love
this there's a new service it's called
cupid dot me and it's a free website
that lets users text and share their
verified STD information so it's
basically a giant database of what do
you have so ain't gotta react l'm IDIA
give me another STD not everything
here's the thing i know it's not and i
was like okay this is kind of dope first
of all kind of kills the mood when
someone's like yo like you're about to
get down they're like let me see the app
that will show you do it before you go
on the right to say wet your Facebook
stock yeah you'll let me know well but
first of all I'm gonna be at some STD
database either way because who knows
that they screw it up and suddenly I'm
like AIDS girl because someone screwed
something up okay but the second part is
this app only shows four things that are
very testable which are chlamydia
gonorrhea syphilis and HIV herpes and
warts which are extremely more rampant
and terrifying me and her permanent will
never go away are not part of this app
so somebody's like you I don't have
chlamydia I'm like who cares you could
take like a pill for that I want to know
if you have herpes
that terrifies me I feel like this app
does nothing for me if they're not
broken out they can still great if you
have chlamydia like so what you probably
could take a pill and that could go away
there's waste scarier things out there
this app does not cover is where an
inherent problem with an opt-in STD app
you know you mean like only a certain
level of people I it could be people
that are trying to be honest
but opting in the point of this is not
that people aren't gonna be able to take
advantage obviously if somebody it has a
disease and they don't want to share
that and they want to have sex
regardless this app is not good that's
not the point of it I think the point of
this is to be able to avoid that awkward
conversation right like early on we like
if people are just wanting to have you
know safe casual sex between two
consenting adults have fun it's not a
relationship it's not whatever you hang
out one time you want to be able to hook
up it's a little awkward to be like okay
so let me see your staff yeah I think
that was the point I made in a terror
I was trying to say is generally and
hopefully if it's somebody that you're
having a one time casual sexual
experience with you're going to use a
condom whether you're trying to prevent
disease or pregnancy or whatever I'm not
judging people that do vers don't choose
whatever you'd like what I'm saying is
the thing on this particular STD app
only has things that are preventable by
condom so a test for chlamydia syphilis
gonorrhea and HIV which are the things
that condoms protect for and the one
thing it can't show you is whether
somebody has herpes or Wars or multitude
of other things or HPV which are other
things that you completely can get while
still using a condom so many a useless
HPV for example basically like 80% of
people about 1/3 have an active viral
outbreak right now and almost all men
don't don't even know they have it they
don't even know they're a stick
something that we're all being techies
here as we've been talking about but to
me this is one of the few things that
actually strikes me as negative and it
also it just it just lends itself to
lying and disconnecting the sex like
then it's such it doesn't go well
somebody in your feelings the other
person doesn't that can spread this and
stop it I want to be in some database
where there could be a mistake I don't
want any girl to be like oh look at
Jenna and she's in the chlamydia
database you'd be like what the hell do
you like verified check yeah I like
Twitter Honoria yeah hear it it's like
that's so personal you want to know
there's this app called STD triage you
can take a picture of your genitals if
you think you have herpes or Werth's or
something and they're looking like you
send it to them and then somebody will
diagnose you which is strange to
diagnose somebody a through an iPhone
and what is I I mean if that's actually
a really really good we can help people
who can't email any pictures of their
kut'r through the internet like might
have herpes and well let's say that
you're a reader for Barry I by the way
that's my favorite scandal Weiner game
but let's say you're a very very poor
person who thinks that they were
recently exposed to their
really scared not able to get through
the day obviously there are free clinics
around but they don't have
transportation there there are many
reasons why say Planned Parenthood's
whatever exactly and so so I think that
that is actually just another kind of
option
yeah individual it's helpful just scares
me that people may think they I don't
know who's on the other end of it they
didn't make it very clear who's
diagnosing it so somebody who may be
carrying something they could say oh no
that just looks like you know you got a
bad bikini wax and they're like I'm cool
no hurry that almost every time it would
say something like that's something you
should be follow up but clearly the
theme of the show has been sort of a
distrust of people and government and
they trust for science and rational
thought and and own your own body
alright I'm gonna let you two this was
the fastest show I think that we ever
did here I'm gonna let you guys pimp
yourselves out you can talk directly to
camera number three
okay well I'm one of the newest members
of The Young Turks so see me on The
Young Turks more often on the main show
on the point on lots of of the sideshows
I also recently oh gosh there's so much
okay I know sorry I'm sorry just check
out my website Cara Santa Maria calm or
Twitter at Cara Santa Maria and you'll
see everything there hello let me go
swirl and at the camera here's where you
can find me I'm just kidding um so yeah
basically the easiest way to find me is
on Twitter which is just at Jenn Hoffman
je and an H o FF ma N or my website and
my blog and my about me and my whole
spiel and links to other stuff is on Jen
Hoffman dot-com there you go and you
guys know you can find me at Rubin
report on Twitter I thank you guys for
watching I will do